maintenant on va aider les enfants qui
sont là à s'exprimer parce que c'est
vous les pop stars du jour vous êtes nos
journalistes en herbe tous les deux
zakaria et kawtar l'un en sixième
l'autre en 5e c'est ça mais ici pas de
bêtises parfait tu m'expliques un petit
peu zakaria comment ça s'est passé là
dans le quartier planoise de ce que ce
que tu as fait pendant les vacances ce
qu'on a fait bas on a fait notre nouveau
reportage la première semaine de pâques
tous les après midi de 14 heures à 16
heures
on a utilisé beaucoup de matériel on à
aller dans cette dans certains parcs
c'est ce qu'on va faire on va regarder
on va regarder le premier reportage
parce que c'est vrai que tu as passé des
vacances avec avec chaos tard dans le
quartier planoise avec l'association
paris vous en avez fait un film avec la
complicité d'un documentariste
je propose de regarder ce petit extrait
de film
malgré la mauvaise réputation du
quartier de planoise les structures
telles que la maison de quartier des
racines et des feuilles
le pkk a et l'association paris propose
d'aider les enfants et adultes pour
améliorer leur condition des noirs mais
bonjour sa carrière bonjour alors
pourquoi vous travailler ici qu'est ce
qui vous a donné envie de travailler à
l'association paris moi je pourrais
aider les enfants
j'aime bien aider les enfants surtout
les enfants de mon quartier ce que
j'aime ce quartier
moi je suis bénévole à la science et
l'association paris depuis
environ
un an et demi je viens environ trois
fois par semaine je fais des aides aux
devoirs des cp jusqu'au collège
je fais aussi un atelier 2
deux français tous les mercredis avec
des 3e et puis pendant les vacances
j'organise aussi des enfin je m'occupe
des stages de français voilà alors
première question je vais te demander
qu'est ce qui sert à l'association paris
je suis là pour travailler
je ne sais pas vrai on le sait tous que
je peux là pour travailler
cela pourrait rigoler m'amuser ce que je
fais à l'association paris je travaille
puisque fin d'année j'ai le bac mais
nouvelles connaissances aussi je suis là
pour rigoler aussi à l'association paris
ont fait de l'aide aux devoirs les
stages de révision
les activités des sorties et des
ateliers associé à son pari est ce que
sa dette sa tête pour l'école ouais
ouais faut pas rigoler avec sa part que
l'association paris ça aide énormément
surtout les personnes en difficulté moi
personnellement je prends en difficulté
mais ouais ça aide présent que quand
j'en ai besoin je viens et puis les
bénévoles ils sont là pour nous céline
aussi par exemple saba ahmed tout le
corps de l'association parier là oui ça
m'aide énormément
qu'est ce que c'est l'association paris
comme alors l'association paris pour moi
c'est c'est plein d'enfants qu'il faut
aider qui qui me
qui nous demande beaucoup d'énergie qui
nous a pour beaucoup de satisfaction
beaucoup de joie et parfois un petit peu
de fatigue et voilà à l'association il y
a plusieurs salles pour accueillir plus
de 400 ans il n'y aurait pas
l'association par ex que tu ferais en
dehors des cours je sais pas j'avais
peut-être autre chose mais c'est pas
qu'on soit peut-être sera sortie
peut-être que je sais pas j'avais vu à
peut-être un peu plus de temps libre
mais c'est pas si mal
c'est magnifique
parce que c'est l'association paris pour
vous commencez c'est bah ça sert sa
serre c'est vraiment une structure très
très importante dans le quartier donc il
existait depuis au moins 40 ans pour
faire donc on a participé on a intervenu
dont bon ce quartier pour produire si on
peut dire delà des générations qui ont
bien réussi
donc bon lorsque l'arrêté dont leur vie
c'est à l'impact très très important car
les enfants l'opportunité de découvrir
de nouvelles activités culturelles grâce
à ces associations contribuent à leur
avenir et enrichissent leurs
connaissances zakaria et kawtar en vous
vois dans le reportage ici sur le
quartier planoise à besançon avec
l'association paris fière de toi kaoutar
ouais ça s'est passé comment pourquoi
le test rétro qu'est ce que tu as le
plus ému par les entend pas vraiment la
tare journalistes ah ouais c'est ce que
tu veux faire plus tard
non c'est pas facile finalement tu vois
quand à face à quelqu'un qui veut pas
forcément répondre pas envie que pour x
ou y raison
voilà ce sens plus ou moins concernés il
faut arriver à tirer les attirer
quelques mois c'est pas toujours très
très évident ça c'est un job quoi
finalement tu voudrais faire quoi t'as
plus tard d'oreilles pardon de douane
donc être douaniers c'est ça ok j'ai
bien compris un l'oit vous avez compris
que moi d'accord parfait j'en reviens à
toi zakaria est ce que tu as travaillé
avec chaos tard sur les images qu'on est
en train de voir là c'est l'autre
reportage qui concerne cette fois ci un
parc saissac hauteur wheelbarrow sur
plein de choses pareilles ouais tu
voulais raconter quoi du parti sis être
bien aussi le coût d'un milliard des
trucs et toi tu le penses tu penses
qu'ils commencent par qu il est bien on
parlait bien ouais et toi zakarian mois
ci mais il ya ce qu'on à aller dans
plusieurs
arc à certains qui étaient plus petits
que d'autres et on a du coup interviewer
des gens pour savoir ce que les gens
pensaient des parcs ne t'en penses quoi
toi il est bien ouais pour mailler bon
d'accord tu veux faire quoi être plus
tard journalistes continuent
kinésithérapeute c'est ça rit et on sent
bien on a un kinésithérapeute en ligne
douanières on est bien encadré le public
seront parfaits bon en tout cas moi je
vous félicite bravo je sais qu'il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont en régie on n'a
pas pu tous les montres et peut-être que
d'ici la fin de l'émission fera une
petite photo de groupe je sais pas on
verra on va on va faire en sorte que en
tout cas je voulais en profiter pour
remercier le clemi le centre pour
l'éducation aux médias et à
l'information qui permet aux élèves
finalement comme vous d'apprendre à lire
à décrypter l'information à l'image et
puis surtout l église et si une seule
chose à retenir les enfants c'est votre
esprit critique et surtout pensez à bien
vous forger une opinion vous laissez pas
aller c'est aussi l'objectif du clemi et
puis c'est un bel échange entre jeunes
et médias c'est une expérience sympa non
on se sent pas bon tout va alors